♪
AFTERNN, YALE COLLE CLASS
OF
21.
[  CHEERS D APPLAUSE ]
WEOME TO THE GRAATES OF
ANFORD,
MORSE,
PIERSON,
SAYBRO,
ANTIMOTHY DWIG COLLEGES,
AND WELCOME TOAMILY, FRIEN,
AND MEMBERS OFHE CLASS W
ARE
JOING US VIRTULY TODAY VIA
TO TREAM. WE AREO EXCITED
HAVERRIVED AT TH SPECIAL
Y. IN A W MOMENTS WE WIL
BEN ANNOUNCINGHE GRADUATES
AS THEPROCESS ACSS THE
E STAGE HERE INRONT OF ME.
PROGRAM, AEW WOR ABO THE
LAND
IS TAKINPLACE.
YA ACKNOWLEDGES AT
INDIGENO PEOPLES ANDATIONS,
INT
PEQUOTEASTERN PEQU,
SCHAGHCOKE, GOLDEN HL
PAUGUSS
QUINNIPIAC A OTHER ALGQUIAN
AND WATERWS OF WHAT IS N S
E
STE OF CONNECTUT. WE HONOR
D RESPECT THE ENDURING
RELATIONSH THAT EXISTS
BETWN
ESPEOPLES ANNATIONS AND
THIS LAND.
THK YOU, AND PASE ENJOY THE
PROGRA
MR. PRESIDENT, I HAVE THHONOR
TO PRESENT CANDIDATES FR
YBROOK COLLEGEOR THE
COLLEGE.HEN THEY HAVE BEEN
RECOMMENDED BY THE FACULTY OF
YALE COLLEGE AND APPROD BY
THE
CORPORATION, DEAN CHUN WILL ASK
YOU BYOUR OFFICIAL A TO
NFER UPON THEM THESE DEGREES.
PRESIDENT PETER SALOVEY:
[  CHEERS AND APPLAU ]
BY THE AUTHORITY VESTED IN ME,
I
SHALL CONFER UPON YOU THE
BACHELOR'S DEGREES IN YALE
COLLEGE WHEN DESIGNATED BY THE
DEAN, AND SHALL THEN ADMIT YOU
TO ALL THEIR RIGHTS AND
RESPONSIBILITIES.
HENRY MAXWELL JACOB
BANNER BEARER OF SAYBROOK CLIJ.
BENJAMIN SAMUEL GROBMAN
MEGAN MARIE SARDIS
JOHN CHINEDU AGOH
JONATHAN FREDERICK ALTMAN
BROOKE CHRISTINA ALVIAR
NICHOLAS ANDERSON
MIA ARIAS TSANG
JASON LUIS ARROYO
MEHDI BAQRI
MARIEL BAROCAS
LUKE PETER GRIFFITH BENSON
KELSEY TAYLOR BOWEN
SYDNEY JORDYN BOWEN
RYAN JOSHUA CAIN
SOFIA HARTMAN CARO
BRIENNA M. CARTER
JOSHUA PETER CELLI
LEO CHEN
SHOUMIK DUTTA CHOWDHURY
CALEB HUME CLOTHIER
CURTIS WILEY COLVETT
EKATERINA DANCHENKO
NICHOLAS CHARLES DEWALT
ARTHUR ALISTAIR DONALD
SARAH ELIZABETH FORCE
JACOB TOBIN GLUCKMAN
JOÃO ANGELO GONÇALVES CARDOSO
EMMA ROSE GRAY
ROHAN KRISHNA GURRAM
PAULINA A. HALLEY
NOA FAITH HINES
MARLENA HINKLE
ERIC FENNER HIRSCH
ANNA SISKO HOWARD
COURTNEY PAIGE HOWARD
AMBER ROYNING HU
EVAN GRACE HUGHES
SHANTANU RAJESH JHA
KAREN JIANG
HARRY AUGUSTUS KAHN
GRACE EUNGIE KANG
TRENT S. KANNEGIETER
BEN KAZLOW-ZIEVE
EUI YOUNG KIM
EMMA BLUE KIRBY
AARON MAASS KLEINER
ADAM SAUL KROK
ELIZABETH ANN LEONARD
ZHENHAO LI
ASHER JOSEPH LIFTIN
BRANDON JOHN LOPEZ
OWEN ALEXANDER MARKS
DAVID LEOPOLDO MCCOWIN
MARIA ROSE MCKINNEY
CATHERINE CAHILL MOLLERUS
NICOLAS ADAM MOSCOSO
WILLIAM SCOTT MUKAMAL
JESSE BRIAN NADEL
AIDAN AUGUST O'CONNOR
TEREZA PODHAJSKÁ
COLLETT SAMUEL WOOLMAN PRESTON
SKYLAR RUBY REGAN
ANTOINETTE DIBBLE ROBERTS
ALYSE REANN ROBINSON
ANTHONY STEVE RODAS ESTRADA
CARLOS ULISES RODRIGUEZ CORTEZ
JUSTIN DYLAN SCHNEIDERMAN
MOLLY GOLDA SHAPIRO
SUKHMANPREET SINGH
RYAN THOMAS STEELE
RAPHAEL LINDER STEINER
AMANDA GISELE THOMAS
ALISON JANE VANDEBUNT
LARA VICTORIA VARELA GAJEWSKI
MICHAEL E. VARGAS
HARISH VEMURI
NEHA VERMA
ANJALI WALIA
CHRISTOPHER G. WEST
AUGUSTE ELIOT WHITE
PHYLICIA LAUREN WILKOV
ALICE GUANYI WU
BRADLEY LI JIAN YAM
MICAH CLEMENS YOUNG
LUCY RUNJIE ZHU
MARY LUI: MR. PRESIDENT, I HAVE
THE HONOR TO PRESENT CANDIDATES
FROM TIMOTHY DWIGHT COLLEGE FOR
HOME OF THE RED LIONS, FOR
THE BACHELOR'S DEGREES IN YALE
COLLEGE. WHEN THEY HAVE BEEN
RECOMMENDED BY THE FACULTY OF
YALE COLLEGE AND APPROVED BY
THE
CORPORATION, DEAN CHUN WILL ASK
YOU BY YOUR OFFICIAL ACT TO
CONFER UPON THEM THESE DEGREES.
[  CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]
>> BY THE AUTHORITY VESTED IN
ME, I
SHALL CONFER UPON YOU THE
BACHELOR'S DEGREES IN YALE
COLLEGE WHEN DESIGNATED BY THE
DEAN, AND SHALL THEN ADMIT YOU
TO ALL THEIR RIGHTS AND
RESPONSIBILITIES.
KINGREY SULLENS
THE BANNER BEARER OF TIMOTHY
DWIGHT COLLEGE
LENA CHAN
ALEXANDER DIMEGLIO
THE PROFESSIONAL MARSHALS OF
TIMOTHY DWIGHT COLLEGE.
EITAN SAMUEL ACKS
ZIAD ABED AHMED
YASMIN L. ALAMDEEN SHAHZADA
LANDON MATTHEW ALLEN
SAMAR ALLIBHOY
REBECCA GLENNA AMONOR
GRACE MORGAN BARTLETT
JOSHUA CHARLES BEASLEY
REZA ELIAS BERGEMANN
INDIA SHANNON SHANTI
BHALLA-LADD
BRITTANY FELECIA BOYCE
ALEXANDRA YURIKA BOYD
NEIL RAHUL BRAGANZA
SARAH NICOLE CAMERON
DEJA KALEILANI CHAPPELL
ASHWIN KANNA CHETTY
MARYANNE REBSTOCK COSGROVE
MARIANNA COSTELETOS
KARINA DANIELA DI FRANCO
ELIZABETH LEE DOLAN
OWEN BEALS DUKE
ELIAS KARIM FARHAT
ERIN LEE GERARDO
SHANNON CAROLYNE GUERRA
HARRY ANDREW HEGEMAN
JACOB C. HINISH
ELEANOR AIDA ISKANDER
SPENCER JOHNSON
TAL JOSEPH
TYLER JOSEPH JOST
MALAK KHAN
NISHANTH KRISHNAN
DEREK AMUR KULDINOW
ALESSANDRA LAROCCO
ALEXANDER EAN LATHEM
ARIADNE ELIZABETH LETROU
IVY LI
ERICA VIVIAN LIN
CHRISTINA VAUGHAN LINDSAY
RUSHYENDRA MAGANTY
ANUSHA MANGLIK
MICHAELLAH MAPOTARINGA
JACOB REUBEN PAUL MEZEY
ANANTH T. MILLER-MURTHY
ANGEL EDOARDO MORA
MINAHIL NAWAZ
AUSTIN PHILLIPS O'TOOLE
ALLIE OLSON
JONATHAN MICHAEL PALACIOS
JACOB PAYNE
ANNA ROSE POLISH
ANNA MERRILL MCCLURE RESIDE
TOBIAH LAURENCE RICHKIND
CAMILA RIVERA SOTO
HENRY ROSAS IBARRA
SAUL ISAAC ROSELAAR
SOPHIA JOY ROSS
GABRIEL VICTOR ROY
ALEJANDRA SALAZAR GONZALEZ
YASH SAMANTARAY
CHRISTIAN LEVAN SAMPLETON
SHREEYA SINGH
ROBERT FRANCIS SKORONSKI
ISAAC DONLE SWIFT
SEYADE TADELE
ANTALIQUE TRAN
JADYN TRAYVICK
RYAN BILGUUN TSEDEVSUREN
MARTY TUNG
ELIAS ARMAND JOHANNES VOSS
EMERY ZELLERS WALLACE
RUIYAN MICHELLE WANG
KENNETH XU
NAHOM YIMAM
AND PARTICIPATING REMOTELY
LAUREN JIHYUN KIM
LUCY SILBAUGH
AND
THOMAS SHANNON VISSMAN
FLAUS
[ APPLAUSE ]
>> MR. PRESIDENT, I HAVE THE
HONOR
TO PRESENT CANDIDATES FROM
MORSE
COLLEGE FOR THE BACHELOR'S
DEGREES IN YALE COLLEGE. WHEN
THEY HAVE BEEN RECOMMENDED BY
THE FACULTY OF YALE COLLEGE AND
APPROVED BY THE CORPORATION,
DEAN CHUN WILL ASK YOU BY YOUR
OFFICIAL ACT TO CONFER UPON
THEM
THESE DEGREES.
[  CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]
>> BY THE AUTHORITY VESTED IN
ME, I
SHALL CONFER UPON YOU THE
BACHELOR'S DEGREES IN YALE
COLLEGE WHEN DESIGNATED BY THE
DEAN, AND SHALL THEN ADMIT YOU
TO ALL THEIR RIGHTS AND
RESPONSIBILITIES.
ZACHARY WILLIAM MILLER
BANNER BEARER OF MORSE COLLEGE
LORENZO VASSILY ARVANITIS
AVA NIKNAHAD
MARSHALS OF MORSE COLLEGE.
NICHOLAS RYAN ABUZALAF
MUSTAFA EMIR AKDERE
JUSTIN AUBIN
MICAH AWODIRAN
CATHERINE NICOLE BENOIT
ANDREW BILODEAU
BRIGITA MAI BURGESS
LUCILLE FRANCES BURTON
NATHALIE JASMIJN BUSSEMAKER
ALEKSANDR ALEKSANDROVICH
BUTOVETSKIY
ALANNAH CAILLAT
TOMAS EDWARD CARRILLO
NATHAN ALEXANDER CHANG
ALLISON ZHUOTING CHEN
YUN MIN CHO
MORGAN SHEA CRONIN
MARIA ELENA CUNNINGHAM
ANASTASIA ROSE DALIANIS
PAIGE HOPKINS DAVIS
JONATHAN WILLIAM DEUBER
CHRISTIAN REID DEVOL
JOSHUA MARK DIAZ
FEYISETAN MOTUNRAYO FALANA
HAILEE ISABELLE GIBADLO
LILLIAN GRACE GOLD
JEREMY GOLDWASSER
DEREK KENNETH GOSHAY
JULIA CHARLOTTE GOURARY
SAMUEL HOWARD GROB
MEGHANLATA ALEXANDRA GUPTA
TANISHA GUPTA
FATEMA HAIDERY
TYLER GU HARMON
NORA MARIE HEAPHY
ARIEL M. HSIEH
COLLEEN MARGARET HUFFMAN
KARTHIK IRAKAM
HALE BORDEN JAEGER
ISABELLA ROSE JENNINGS
CLAIRE SALLY KALIKMAN
AYLA KHAN
JAMES CURTIS LARGE II
TAT WEI LEE
JAKE JOSEPH LEVIN
SANDRA LI
VUONG VUONG MAI
SAUMYA MALHOTRA
STEPHANIE MARIE MALTA
BRIAN CALLAHAN MATTHEWS
HANNAH CAMILLE MELCHINGER
CATHERINE CLARE MORNEAU
COURTNEY MONIQUE NUNLEY
CHAYTON ANTHONY PABICH
NICHOLAS ARMAND PADIN
DANTE MICHAEL PALECCO
NIKHIL SANJAY PATEL
SAMUEL TIMOTHY PEKAREK
JORDAN CUNNINGHAM PERRY
BRANDON JAMES PETERSON
DANIEL ANTONIO PITA
SHAUN WILLIAM RADGOWSKI
BENJAMIN COLTON ROBB
IAN M. SALVAMOSER
RASMUS PETER LILLIOS SCHLUTTER
TYLER YANG SHEN
JENNA YE RIN SHIN
MATTHEW BRYAN SPERO
ABHISHEK SRINIVAS
ZACHARY CARL STANIK
ARMIN MATHEW THOMAS
ADAM NEAL TUCKER
ZHENGDONG WANG
CAMERON MATTHEW WARFIELD
NICOLE MARIE WATTERS
LILY FRANCES WEISBERG
TYLER HARRISON WELSH
HARRY D. WESTBROOK
LEAH HANNAH XIAO
DANIEL DOV YADIN
ALICE ELIZABETH YAN
TONY XIANGWEN ZENG
HELEN ZHAO
AND GRADUATES PARTICIPATING
REMOTELY
RENEE ONG
PARKER DUQUESNE REDCROSS
EVAN MICHAEL SCHAEFFER
MR. PRESIDENT, I HAVE THE HONOR
TO PRESENT CANDIDATES FROM
BRANFORD COLLEGE FOR THE
BACHELOR'S DEGREES IN YALE
COLLEGE. WHEN THEY HAVE BEEN
RECOMMENDED BY THE FACULTY OF
YALE COLLEGE AND APPROVED BY
THE
CORPORATION, DEAN CHUN WILL ASK
YOU BY YOUR OFFICIAL ACT TO
CONFER UPON THEM THESE DEGREES.
[  CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]
PRESIDENT PETER SALOVEY:
BY THE AUTHORITY VESTED IN ME,
I
SHALL CONFER UPON YOU THE
BACHELOR'S DEGREES IN YALE
COLLEGE WHEN DESIGNATED BY THE
DEAN, AND SHALL THEN ADMIT YOU
TO ALL THEIR RIGHTS AND
RESPONSIBILITIES.
[ APPLAUSE ]
LESLIE CARMIN:
AKHIL VIKRAMADITYA RAJAN
THE BANNER BEARER OF BRANFORD
COLLEGE
ATHENA RENEE FLINT
SHALHEVET SCHWARTZ
PROCESSION MARSHALS OF
BRANFORD COLLEGE.
ANISSA KIM ABBOUD
JOSEPH DAVID ALLEN
VALENTINA AMATE PEREZ
LAKSHMI RIVERA AMIN
NICHOLAS J. ARCHAMBAULT
ISABELLA MARIE BACK
ALEC JEAN BERNAL
GABRIELLE GENE BRANIN
MICHAEL CHAU
GABRIELLE COLANGELO
WESLEY DAY
SEILA VANESSA DE LEON
DAVID OKON EDIMO
ROHAN GARG
LOUIS ELIJAH GOLDSMITH
ANDREA GORODEZKY
AÏSSA DJENNE GUINDO
THEODORE JEFFREY HAGUE
LAUREN JESSICA HARRIS
CIARAN HASSAN
GRACE WORTHINGTON HAVILAND
JAMES CLAYTON HEBERT
YEAMA YI-RAN HO
AUDREY YINGAN HUANG
DANA NORBERT JOSEPH
SAMUEL BEN KATZ
UNIQUE CHEON KIM
NOAH MARCUS KOPF
JOONG CHANG LEE
SELENA
THU-LAN LEE
KEYI LI
MICHAEL DAVIDSON LINDEN
VIVIAN KAY MAYERS
LUCY ALICE MCEWAN
KATHY MAE MIN
MAXWELL TYLER MODEL
JACK MORTON
KEATON IRVING MUELLER
ALLISON MINA PARK
MAYA PASIC
THOMAS CLARKE POINTER
CAROLINA LIMA PORCILE
THOMAS A.G. QUIJANO
AGASHA KAREEF RATAM
ALEXANDER JAMES REEDY
JASMINE TERESA RIOS
WILLIAM CLARENCE RODGERS III
ETHAN R. ROSS
GEORGE KYRIACOS SABATAKAKIS
ANDREW SHEINBERG
ANNA F. SMIST
ARIELLE SOLDATENKO
SHAO-CHI TANG
VY QUYNH TRAN
JEREMY LOVELL UYS
I'M GLAD YOU CAME.
HANNAH VERMA
VOD YURHI VILFORT
MELINDA YOUNG WANG
ELISABETH LENEHAN WANGERMANN
ETHAN MORGAN WILLIAMS
ALVIN MAURICE WINSTON II
ALLAN LEE WU
SORRY.
TIMOTHY DORJE WU
WYATT JACKSON YESS
VANESSA JIAHUI ZHANG
GRADUATES PARTICIPATING
REMOTELY
GRACE VIOLET CHUNG, CONNOR
DOWNY
JONAS,
MICHELLE KEN
THANK YOU.
[ APPLAUSE ]
MR. PRESIDENT, I HAVE THE HONOR
TO PRESENT CANDIDATES FROM
PIERSON COLLEGE FOR THE
BACHELOR'S DEGREES IN YALE
COLLEGE. WHEN THEY HAVE BEEN
RECOMMENDED BY THE FACULTY OF
YALE COLLEGE AND APPROVED BY
THE
CORPORATION, DEAN CHUN WILL ASK
YOU BY YOUR OFFICIAL ACT TO
CONFER UPON THEM THESE DEGREES.
>> BY THE AUTHORITY VESTED IN
ME, I SHALL CONFER UPON YOU THE
BACHELOR'S DEGREES IN YALE
COLLEGE, WHEN DESIGNATED BY THE
DEAN, AND SHALL SHEN ADMIT YOU
TO ALL THEIR RIGHTS AND
RESPONS
RESPONSIBILITIES.
KARENA ZHAO
THE BANNER BEARER OF PIERSON
COLLEGE
ROYCE PENN LEE
AND
NIGEL CONNOR WADE
THE PROCESSION MARSHALS OF
PIERSON COLLEGE
ADRIANA RUBY ARCIA
AISHWARYA BHATTACHARYA
JONATHAN BOULAPHINH
VERONICA CHEN
JUSTIN HOANG CHEONG
BRANDON NICHOLAS COBB
ALEXIS CAROLANN COOK
CHARLOTTE GRACE COOPERMAN
QUINCY MONTGOMERY CRAWFORD IV
KIMBERLY CRUZ BUSTAMANTE
ALEC DAI
KIMBERLEY DAO
CLAIRE M. DAVIDSON
GREGORY DIMITRI DELLIS
IAN AKIRA DENZER
VICTORIA L. DOMBROWIK
EDWARD N. DOROBEK
REBECCA CATALINA DRACHMAN
ALANA SIMONE EILAND
MATTHEW LOUIS FANTOZZI
MATHEW L. FERRARO
BENJAMIN SOL FREEDMAN
JOHN PATRICK FRITH, JR.
ALEXANDRA CHRISANTHE GODRON
COURTNEY ELIZABETH GREEN
ARIANNA LENA HAIRSTON
OSCAR HEDIN
KRISTEN ELIZABETH HENRY
REYES
RETANA
WILLIAM HU
GRACE JIN
THOMAS GEORGE JOHNSON
TRINIDAD ALIN KECHKIAN
EMILIE ELIZABETH KILFOIL
LUCAS YONG-BIN KIM
LAUREN ELISABETH VICTORIA LEE
JAYLAN EVERLAY LEON
JOY LIAN
LEIGH JOSEPHINE LOGAN
MELISSA DAI LU
VICTORIA WENDY MAK
MOHAMMAD AMIR MAKHMUDOV
KATIE MALISON
ORVEN FROIE MALLARI
NORA C. MOREAU
DAN L. NGUYEN
KEVIN DAVID O'NEIL
CHRISTINE MARIE OBERHAUSEN
MIKE HAWII OGEGO
ADEDEJI O. PALMER
NANDAN VINU PATEL
CAMILLE VIEN PHAM
LAURYN DAWN PHINNEY
SOPHIE D. POLLACK
SEBASTIAN BARUNGI RUGUNDA
QUAADE
LAUREN ASHLEY QUINTELA
CALEB THOYER RHODES
JOSEPH RIBAUDO
JARED BRANDON ROCK
URSULA LUCILA RODRIGUEZ
BARTOLOMEO RONDELLI
NEELAM KAUR SANDHU
ISABEL SOPHIA SANDS
THOMAS HENRY SCHACHT
YOUNGMIN SHIN
TAYLOR SPADORY
ELIANA ROSE SWERDLOW
NICOLAS VICTOR TABIO
KAREN YANG TAI
TANNER JOHN TAVRYTZKY
TYLER ALEXANDER TAVRYTZKY
JAYSON TUAN THOMPSON
CAMILLE ELLEN UMOFF
DANIEL KENNETH URKE
MILAN GOVINDA VIVANCO
ERIC YIYANG WANG
TODD MITCHELL WARSHAWSKY
SHERRY WU
VICKY WU
VIVIAN XU
LILLIAN YUAN
AHMAD ZAIDI
ANNIE ZHOU
[ APPLAUSE ]
PRESIDENT PETER SALOVEY:  TO
THE
STUDENTS OF THE CLASS OF 2021
AND THEIR PARENTS, FAMILIES,
AND
FRIENDS LOOKING ON FROM AROUND
THE GLOBE.
WE GATHER TO
RECOGNIZE THE EXTRAORDINARY
ACCOMPLISHMENTS OF ALL OF YOU
WHO HAVE WORKED SO HARD TO
COMPLETE YOUR PROGRAMS OF
STUDY.
WE SALUTE YOUR EFFORT, YOUR
DILIGENCE, YOUR TALENT, AND
YOUR
INTELLECT. WE ALSO JOIN YOU IN
EXPRESSING GRATITUDE FOR ALL
WHO
HAVE SUPPORTED YOU IN THESE
ENDEAVORS: YOUR FAMILIES AND
FRIENDS, TEACHERS, AND OTHER
MEMBERS OF THE YALE COMMUNITY.
CONGRATULATIONS, CLASS OF 2021!
[  CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]
CURTIS COLVETT: HELLO, CLASS OF
2021! MY NAME IS CURTIS
COLVETT,
AND I AM YOUR CLASS TREASURER.
FOUR YEARS HAVE GONE BY IN THE
BLINK OF AN EYE. WE'VE MADE SO
MANY MEMORIES, FROM THE
FIRST-YEAR SNOWBALL FIGHT ON
OLD
CAMPUS TO THE YALE-HARVARD
FOOTBALL GAME OF 2019, WHERE WE
WON IN DOUBLE-OVERTIME, TO ALL
OF THE LATE NIGHTS, WHETHER
THEY
BE IN THE LIBRARY STUDYING FOR
AN EXAM OR IN THE COMMON ROOM
TALKING WITH OUR FRIENDS AND
SUITEMATES.
ALTHOUGH OUR SENIOR YEAR
EXPERIENCE WAS CERTAINLY NOT A
TRADITIONAL ONE, THE CLASS OF
2021 MADE THE BEST OF THE
SITUATION. WHEN WE LEAVE YALE
IN
JUST A FEW DAYS, WE WILL LEAVE
WITH MEMORIES AND FRIENDSHIPS
THAT WILL LAST A LIFETIME.
HERE'S TO THE CLASS OF 2021! WE
DID IT!
CONGRATULATIONS!
[  CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]
>> CLASS OF 2021, GOOD
AFTERNOON!
[  CHEERS ]
MY NAME IS AKHIL RAJAN, AND I
AM
A MEMBER OF THE COMMITTEE THAT
ORGANIZED CLASS DAY, WHICH WILL
AIR ON YOUTUBE TOMORROW AT 2:30
P.M. TWO MINUTES BEFORE 2:30,
AT
2:28 P.M., A SPECIAL PIECE
WRITTEN BY CLASS DAY SPEAKER,
ROBERT LOPEZ, WILL BE PLAYED
FROM HARKNESS TOWER, SO KEEP
YOUR EARS OPEN. IF YOU HAVEN'T
ALREADY DECORATED A FUNNY HAT
FOR CLASS DAY, IT'S NOT TOO
LATE.
IN FACT, ON YOUR SEAT
TODAY, YOU RECEIVED A CLASS DAY
2021 HAT THAT YOU MIGHT WANT TO
USE FOR THAT VERY PURPOSE.
YOU'LL
ALSO FIND A GIFT BAG, WHICH
INCLUDES ITEMS THAT REPRESENT
LONGSTANDING CLASS DAY
TRADITIONS, AS WELL AS OTHERS
THAT ARE YU  UNIQUE TO THE
CLASS OF 2021. IN ADDITION TO
THE CLASS DAY SPEAKER,
TOMORROW'S PROGRAM ALSO
INCLUDES
REMARKS BY MEMBERS OF OUR CLASS
WHO HAVE PUT TOGETHER
OUTSTANDING ORIGINAL SPEECHES.
AND, BECAUSE CLASS DAY IS ABOUT
ALL OF US, YOU'LL SEE YOUR
PHOTOGRAPHS AND VIDEO
REFLECTIONS THROUGHOUT
TOMORROW'S PROGRAM.
AS WELL.
CONGRATULATIONS, CLASS OF 2021,
AND SEE YOU TOMORROW AT CLASS
DAY!
[ APPLAUSE ]
>> CLASS OF 2021,
CONGRATULATIONS AGAIN.
I AM SO HAPPY
TO BE WITH YOU AND CELEBRATE
WITH YOU TODAY. GRADUATING IS A
GREAT ACCOMPLISHMENT, ONE OF
THE
MOST IMPORTANT ONES OF YOUR
LIFE. IF YOU THINK BACK TO WHEN
YOU FIRST ARRIVED ON CAMPUS, NO
ONE COULD HAVE IMAGINED THAT
YOU
WOULD LIVE THROUGH A GLOBAL
PANDEMIC BEFORE REACHING THIS
MOMENT. BUT YOU DID, AND THANKS
TO YOUR STRENGTH AND
PERSEVERANCE, THIS MOMENT HAS
FINALLY COME. I AM
HONORED TO RECOGNIZE ALL THE
WORK THAT YOU HAVE
DONE TO GET HERE, MUCH OF IT
WITH THE SUPPORT OF YOUR FAMILY
AND FRIENDS. TODAY IS YOUR
DAY, AND IT IS THEIRS TOO.
TODAY IS A DAY FOR LOOKING
BACK WITH PRIDE AT EVERYTHING
YOU HAVE ACCOMPLISHED AND ALL
THE GOALS YOU HAVE REACHED. OF
COURSE IT BRINGS SOME SADNESS,
TOO, NOW THAT YOU ARE ENDING
YOUR BRIGHT COLLEGE YEARS. BUT
TODAY IS A COMMENCEMENT, A
BEGINNING, SO NOW, AS YOU LOOK
TO THE DAYS AND YEARS AHEAD,
THINK OF THE NEW ACHIEVEMENTS
AND OPPORTUNITIES IN FRONT OF
YOU. AND LOOK AROUND AS WELL,
TO
REMIND YOURSELF OF THE
EXCELLENT
COMPANY JOINING ON THIS NEW
BEGINNING ━ YOUR FRIENDSHIPS
FORMED AT YALE.
TOMORROW YOU WILL CELEBRATE
CLASS DAY ━ A TRADITION
STRETCHING BACK 150 YEARS IN
YALE COLLEGE HISTORY. I AM
EXCITED TO  WATCH THE VIRTUAL
PROGRAM ALONGSIDE YOU AND TO
ON MONDAY WE CAN LOOK FORWARD
TO PRESIDENT SALOVEY'S
COMMENCEMENT ADDRESS.
I'M
GRATEFUL TO THE CLASS DAY
COMMITTEE, TO THE SENIOR CLASS
COUNCIL, TO
THE UNIVERSITY SECRETARY'S
OFFICE, TO YOUR COLLEGE HEADS
AND DEANS, AND TO EVERYONE WHO
CONTRIBUTED TO MAKING THE
SPECIAL EVENTS OF THIS WEEKEND
POSSIBLE. AND I'M MOST
APPRECIATIVE TO YOU, FOR ALL
THAT YOU HAVE BROUGHT TO YALE━-
AND NOW WILL BRING OUT INTO THE
WORLD WITH YOU.
AGAIN, CLASS OF 2021,
CONGRATULATIONS!
[  CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]
♪